[Music]
so now we're going to look at monitoring
systems an important aspect of what's
going on in various systems and are they
working correctly so monitoring tools
are pretty important for production
environments you can't really have a
complex production environment without
some kind of monitoring tool and they'll
monitor various components whether it be
a service switches or applications or
services so the idea is that when
something goes wrong it'll generate an
alert and then it'll also generate
another alert when the problem has been
solved so we're going to look at several
tools one of them is Nagios the first
one Nagios is an open source monitoring
tool it's looks at network services and
it can monitor things like CPU usage and
other resources like disks and and looks
at the log files it has scripts which
are plugged into it which can be written
in any popular scripting language so you
just basically write a plug-in script
and it will do a certain monitoring job
now lucky else has a number of agents
which have got various names which are
typically acronyms so the Nagios remote
plug-in executors it's basically an
agent which allows scripts to be run on
remote machines it's often used for
monitoring resources like CPU and disk
usage and who's logged in at the time so
what happens is that on each of the
remote machines you have the at the
agent running and it's the nag Leo's
poles the agent on each of them at
remote machines which causes it to
execute the various scripts and get
information from them this Lina Geass
remote data processor is another agent
which allows you to use different
protocols like HTTP and news XML to
transfer information across to the
various agents just another component of
the Nagios system there's also the NS
client + + which is for Windows machines
it's typically used for monitoring
resources like CPU and disk and again it
does a polling operation Nagios polls
the agent on a particular port number
for events so another monitoring tool is
genius
this is fairly sophisticated
it's a basically a three-tier
architecture and you've got these three
different layers inside it so you've got
the instrumentation layer which is the
bottom layer really and you've got these
things called net probes and these are
agents which sit on the monitored system
components and reports back to the
central service you've got then analysis
and consolidation layer which enables it
the doodlenet pros to be deployed and
for the data to be processed and then
you've got a visualization layer which
is a front-end these are called active
consoles so you can see the status of
the environment and see what's going on
at the moment see if there are any
current alerts undergoing so this kind
of gives you the genius architecture
you've got the net probes at the bottom
they're actually the instrumentation
they're sitting on the actual
applications that are running monitoring
the applications by having the means
they're actually implemented then each
of those is grouped together and managed
by one of these gateways which has a
number of rules associated with it and a
compute engine and a knowledge base so
she can analyze the data that comes back
from the net probes and then you've got
the active consoles which give you the
the view the visualization of what is
actually happening within the genius
environment okay so a short section on
those two tools there they basically
just sit there monitoring the system and
reporting back
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here